Sebastian Lege verrät euch, wie veganer
Käse hergestellt wird.
Was macht die vegane Variante so teuer und schmecken die Tester den Unterschied zum Original?
Wir machen den Test!
Vegan-Käsescheiben ähneln jungem Gouda.
Den gibt es im Supermarkt schon für
unter 70 Cent pro 100 Gramm.
Die veganen Alternativen kosten über einen Euro mehr.
Das gleiche gilt für Pizzakäse.
Auch hier ist das tierische Produkt mit im Schnitt 1,13 Euro viel günstiger als die vegane Konkurrenz.
Nicht anders sieht es bei Frischkäse aus.
Vegan ist er sechsmal so teuer.
Und auch beim Parmesan satte Preisunterschiede!
Das vegane Produkt ist pro
100 Gramm zwei Euro teurer.
Branchen-Insider Sebastian Lege weiß: Mit hochwertigen Zutaten hat das alles
nichts zu tun.
Mit einem eigenen Vegan-Käse will er zeigen,
wie bei der Herstellung gespart wird.
Als Milchersatz nimmt Sebastian Mandelwasser.
Dazu vermengt er 20 Mandeln mit
rund einem Liter Wasser im Mixer.
Mandeln sind reich an Fett und Protein und schmecken nicht zu intensiv.
SEBASTIAN: "Fertig ist die Mandelmilch."
Erinnert wirklich an Milch, ist aber deutlich
günstiger als das tierische Rohprodukt.
Für ein Kilo Käsealternative braucht
Sebastian nur 20 Mandeln.
Die kosten nicht mehr als 30 Cent.
Milch ist teurer, selbst bei einem
Erzeugerpreis von 33 Cent pro Liter.
Denn für ein Kilo Käse braucht man rund
zehn Liter.
Macht zusammen über drei Euro.
SEBASTIAN: "Käse hat ja viel Fett. Wir brauchen die vegane Alternative, Kokosöl."
"Davon ordentlich!"
Das Fett aus der Kuhmilch sorgt beim
Käse für Konsistenz und Geschmack.
Sebastian nimmt für sein Vegan-
Produkt 250 Gramm Kokosfett.
Zusätzliche Kosten: gut 1 Euro.
SEBASTIAN: "Dann nehmen wir hier unser Mandelprotein-Wasser."
Damit sich die Mandelmilch jetzt mit dem Fett verbindet, gibt er beides erneut in den Mixer.
Notfalls hilft ein Emulgator aus Soja.
SEBASTIAN: "Super Basis! Jetzt fehlt natürlich der Geschmack."
"Käsearoma! Hochkonzentriert."
"Ein, zwei Tropfen reichen und, bums,
schmeckt alles nach Käse!"
SEBASTIAN: "Reicht."
Für die Farbe sorgt Betacarotin.
Eine winzige Menge genügt.
Fehlen noch etwas Stärke als
Bindemittel und Salz für den Geschmack.
Alles gut mixen und fertig ist die
vegane Kreation mit Käsegeschmack.
SEBASTIAN: "Sieht schon mal sehr käsig aus!"
"Machen wir mal eine kleine Gegenprobe - farblich."
"Ja, nicht so schlecht!"
Traditioneller Käse braucht viel Zeit, um Farbe, Konsistenz und Geschmack zu entwickeln.
Oft Wochen, Monate oder gar Jahre!
Für seinen veganen Pseudo-Käse kocht der Produktentwickler die Mixtur einmal kurz auf.
Schon verbinden sich Wasser, Fett und
Stärke miteinander.
SEBASTIAN: "Sieht aus wie Vanillepudding!"
"Ich würde sagen, der zieht Fäden wie echter geschmolzener Käse."
Insgesamt hat Sebastian Waren
im Wert von rund 2 Euro eingesetzt.
Und auch der Zeitaufwand ist gering.
Die Mixtur muss nur noch abkühlen,
um schnittfest zu werden.
SEBASTIAN: "Fertig ist die Käsealternative!"
In einem Kilogramm echtem Gouda stecken
mehrere Liter Milch und eine lange Reifezeit.
Leges Turbokäse ist schon nach ein paar Stunden fertig.
SEBASTIAN: "Richtig schön fest geworden!"
"Sehr schön."
Das Kilo für gerade einmal zwei Euro.
Sebastian könnte seine Eigenkreation
jetzt als veganen Käseersatz verkaufen.
Aber natürlich nicht ohne vorherigen Geschmackstest...
SEBASTIAN: "Riecht nach Käse, sieht
aus wie Käse, ist aber nur eine Alternative."
"Da bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob da
jemand den Unterschied schmeckt."
Wir laden zur Verkostung in einer
Berliner Markthalle.
Appetitlich angerichtet und
serviert auf einem Stück Brot.
Kommt uns jemand auf die Schliche?
Merken die Tester, dass das kein Käse aus Milch ist?
TESTERIN 1: "Der Käse schmeckt ganz würzig.
Ganz lecker!"
TESTERIN 2: "Wie der Käse, den mein Opa immer gegessen hat, schmeckt der."
"Schmeckt ein bisschen nach Lidl-Gouda."
TESTERIN 3: "Also, wenn man einen neutralen Käse möchte, dann ist man  mit dem ganz gut bedient."
"Gästen würde ich es jetzt nicht unbedingt vorsetzen."
Geschmacklich also kein Highlight.
TESTERIN 4: "Der schmeckt für mich gar nicht nach Käse. Der sieht aus wie Käse, ja."
"Aber er hat einen unerwarteten Beigeschmack."
TESTER: "Vom Geschmack her erinnert der mich an diesen typischen einzelnd eingeschweißten Toastkäse."
"Der schmeckt ein bisschen so wie Analogkäse."
Viele der Tester halten die vegane Käsealternative einfach nur für billigen Käse.
Einen der Tester erinnert sie sogar an Analogkäse
Solche Käseimitat auf Pizzen und
Backwaren sorgten vor Jahren für Schlagzeilen.
Verboten waren wie zwar nicht, durften
aber nicht als Käse verkauft werden.
SCHAUTZ: "Wenn ich mir die Zutatenlisten dieser veganen Käsealternative heute anschaue,
dann sieht die sehr sehr ähnlich wie die vom früheren Analogkäse."
"Denn die Inhaltsstoffe müssen bei veganen Lebensmitteln nicht besser sein."
"Gerade die veganen Käsealternativen beinhalten viele gesättigte Fette, die der Verbraucher
eigentlich eher meiden sollte."
Unter den Zutaten findet sich häufig auch Kokosfett und das ist reich an gesättigten Fettsäuren.
Vegane Käseprodukte sind also nicht automatisch gesünder und günstiger schon gar nicht.
SCHAUTZ: "Diese Produkte sind relativ teuer. Vegan ist hip, aber natürlich
bezahlt der Verbraucher dieses Lifestyle-Produkt."
Denn der Verzicht auf Zutaten oder Hilfsmittel tierischer Herkunft macht Produkte nicht zwingend teurer.
Das gilt nicht nur für vegane Käsealternativen. Auch andere Ersatzprodukte wie Wurst und Fleischimitate
bestehen zum größten Teil aus Wasser
und anderen günstigen Zutaten.
Unterm Strich also ein lukratives Kalkül
mit dem guten Gewissen der Kunden.
Was haltet ihr von der veganen Käsealternative?
Und welche Veggieprodukte schmecken euch am besten?
Schreibt es uns in die Kommentare!
Und wo es die besten Lebensmittel gibt
und was wirklich drin steckt, zeigen wir
euch auf unserem Kanal ZDFbesseresser!